[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les jeudis du caf est en ce moment dans
les marseillais sachez le il ya
tellement de bruit chez les marseillais
que parfois on est un petit peu paumé
vous le savez on s'intéresse à toutes
les émissions de télé réalité et cette
fois c'est benjamin qui essaie
d'expliquer l'origine des clashs à son
ami pas gars vous allez voir que même
lui il comprend plus pourquoi ils sont
brouillées regarder alex a appris la
naissance toute ronde aventure si elle
et alix elle était enfant avait dit
c'est parce qu'elle a pris la défense de
mélanie le premier jour puisque sa patte
les six manon elle était enfant et alix
c'est parce que justement elle a mal
parlé de maintenant justement parce que
alix est en froid avec mila
donc maintenant se montrer la mx
tout ça par an de quoi parce que alix
après à défendre
mais c'est un truc de fou mais je vous
rappelle pour joue toujours pour le
chroniqueur maquiller hashtag masque
chroniqueur mais un mec que j'adore mon
les marseillais c'est greg le gars il
sort avec une meuf mais comme ils sont
que ça va se terminer
il commence déjà à chine et d'autres 9,6
mais sur d'autres dossiers et s'y tient
on a essayé de poser des jalons comme on
dit
alors sauf que sa nouvelle chérie à la
compris double jeu elle n'a pas du tout
envie qu'ils se foutent de sa gueule
ok la cram et le dos voilà écoutez bien
l'argument de greg pour la convaincre
le gars est magnifique françois il ya
des leçons à prendre garde de passer à
autre chose je suis entré là de façon
concentrée sur ma position je m'appelle
quand tu es vraiment passé à l'instant
de dire quoi en fait
mais ça veut dire que t'es pas avec moi
c'est à combler notre d'oublier en fait
je comprends
[Applaudissements]
mais ça qu'on soit oubli soit oublie que
j'adore en traîneau non mais c'est
exceptionnel
castany savoureux semble ça oui ça
m'agace anissa tout craché ils étaient
contents ce week-end il m'a appelé
voulait m'invite à dîner avec sa femme
m'appelle m'appelle je vois ton numéro
elle sans rigoler c'est vrai la femme de
castaldi maple qu'est-ce que je veuille
ou non il ya eu une embrouille
[Rires]
je m'appelle que fois chez soit et non
je crois qu'il était ma vie j'étais ton
billet vert vous avez deviné ou pas quoi
vous êtes allés dîner ou pas du tout
autre chose à [ __ ] sentiment war iv
nord elle m'a dit c ur ultérieurement
des jeunes est inquiète pas me mais je
suis complètement non je les adore la
femme de benjamin aurore je t'embrasse
fort et on va dîner ensemble
jussie peut ne pas y avoir des jugements
ça mange non mais même où sam beaucoup
la facture et moi et là toute la famille
castany cd amour fait récente levée
c'est vrai belgique est devenue un la
maison du bonheur ch ouais ouais sa
maison du bonheur
sauf qu'à chaque fois que tu mettes de
mon habit est quand même assez grand
tour c'est tombé alors tout le monde a
peur de lui dire là dans la villa sauf
les portes regarde
balla balla basse te plaît arrête mais
je parie fortement depuis les airs
souple et surtout d'intelligences donc
là je fais les classes enfin je fais les
420 et la dépouille
je me suis pété darmon
[Musique]
ans
5 décembre par les 400 passionnés jeu
permet de rectifier l année quatre
ascensions elle a fait les quatre cents
pas alors c'est pas grave on est vrai
que l'on sait c'est votre péché mignon
vous attendez tous les lundis d
expression presque français voilà de nos
amis de la télé réalité et bien je n'ai
qu'une chose à vous dire chez vous en ce
jour férié vous eric naulleau régalez
vous le lieu du duel
je montre à mélanie de quel bois je file
à coup plus en vouloir mais tu vas te
taire avec toi le plus ils vont par la
suite je suis encore au kenya c'est
possible non tu m'accuses
déjà vu ou à un m'as-tu-vu c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a dit tu sais que ça
raconte un peu tous nos projets vraiment
pour des tonnes
[Applaudissements]
abattus les chiens dans la moule de quel
droit je me suis inquiet alors ça moment
fatidique dans la bataille des coûts
puisque je te coupe doit faire face à un
dilemme puisqu'il ya bataille des
couples sur tf6
on n'a pas compris le concept mais c'est
une bataille avec des coupes alors ils
doivent faire face à un dilemme ou
partager leur cagnotte ou voulait voler
la cagnotte du couple d'en face alors ça
paraît simple
voilà comme ça le dilemme idée simple
zéro on garde notre cagnotte on partage
notre cagnotte ou bien on vole la
cagnotte du groupe d'enfants bah ça
paraît simple et en fait ni l'animateur
ni les candidats eux-mêmes n'arrive à
comprendre les règles du jeu regardez
vous avez donc chacun une ardoise
si vous partagez tous les deux à ce
moment-là nous partageons les gains si
vous décidez de tenter de voler tous les
deux à ce moment là personne ne gagne
rien vous pouvez choisir de partager ce
gain ou de le voler mais s'il a un
partage et que l'autre vol à ce moment
là c'est le voleur qui rafle tout il
fallait gagner partager bah si tu vas
peut-être que je gagne ainsi tu partages
peut-être que tu voles si tu voi et que
l'autre ils veulent aussi tout compris
[Applaudissements]
alors ça y est c'est déjà la dernière
sur un ruck république dominicaine pour
nos candidats
ça fait déjà quatre semaines qui sont
tournage et forcément ce sont un peu les
stars de lille a maintenant ça y est on
les connaît on s'imagine bien évidemment
que les touristes et les fans les arrête
pour prendre des selles fille alors
imaginez la dernière soirée en boîte de
la folie on croit que ça est la folie et
ben en fait pas du tout du tout regardez
[Musique]
c'est bien
du temps
on rigole bien mais je vois mon chéri
m'oublie pas au milieu de toute cette
foule dense ambiance regarder les choix
portés les gros bisous